رغم ان عمرها لا يتعدل 15 عاما الا ان
الجانب في الامضه يوم عمل كامل مع سفير
بريطانيا في لبنان فهي ايضا سفيره ولكن
لاربع وعشرين ساعه فقط في مبادره لتكريم
المراه خلال يومها العالمي
رافقت الجنيفر السفيره الى مؤسسات انسانيه
ومقرات حكوميه بعد اختيارها من اصل 500
فتاه شاركنا في مسابقه تمحورت حول افكار
لانشاء مجتمع عادل في تجربه حلوه اول شيء
ما خبرت من شركه بس وقتها اتصلوا فيي
خبارته وكان كتير فخوره
انه في عالم انه عنجد بيهتموا كان عنا
واحده من 12 فتاه تتراوح اعمارهن بين 15
و18 عاما رافقنا سفارات تسعه دول بينها
الولايات المتحده واسبانيا واستراليا
وكندا والاردن اضافه الى ممثلين عن ثلاث
منظمات دوليه
سعدنا بوجود جينيفر كسفيره اليوم هذا جزء
من مهام متعدده نقوم بها في لبنان والعالم
حقوق النساء يوم جنيفر كان حافلا لان يوم
السفير يكون عاده مليء بالانشطه زرنا وزير
البيئه ومؤسسه الهادي لذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه التي تدعمها السفاره البريطانيه
بعد لقاء بالشابات اعتقد ان مستقبل لبنان
بايد امينه
المبادره التي اطلقتها السفاره البريطانيه
تهدف الى تعزيز ثقه الشابات بانفسهن
وتدريبهن على اسس العمل الدبلوماسي الذي
قد يفتح الباب امام غد افضل في شهر المراه
العالمي توحدت السفارات حول المراه
اللبنانيه واهميه دعم فتيات سيكون مرحله
التغيير في المستقبل غنوه يتيم العربيه
بيروت